[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro du
débrief du dock retour sur le
documentaire athlètes et transgenres le
double challenge avec notre invité l
sandra forgues bonjour et merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france vous naissez
dans le corps d'un garçon prénommé
wilfried vous fait carrière comme
kayakistes médaille d'or aux jeux
olympiques de 1996 et puis en 2016 vous
faites votre coming out trans et vous
entreprenez votre transition sous le
prénom de sandra vous avez alors 46 ans
quand est ce que vous prenez conscience
que quelque chose ne va pas mettre votre
corps
alors je prends conscience très très tôt
en fait vers l'âge de 7 ans et plus
anciens souvenirs à remonter ses taux
j'utilisais mes robes mais mes cape de
zorro et aimer déguisement pour faire
des jupes et les robes donc c'est là que
j'ai les plus vieux souvenirs mais je
crois que c'est ancré dès la naissance
en fait donc par contre c'est vrai que
dans les années 80 on n'en parlait pas
donc j'ai évacué ce là où j'essayais de
l'évacuer et je me suis réfugié dans le
corps du sportif ce qui a bien marché au
demeurant et on va en parler mais vous
êtes installé dans votre vie lorsque
vous faites ce choix de la transition
vous êtes mariés vous êtes papa de deux
enfants vous vivez de très longues
années avec ce lourd secret pourquoi est
ce qu'un jour on décide de tout révéler
de passer à l'acte aussi en changeant de
fexhe tout simplement ça devient vital
quoi c'est quelque chose c'est très
violent à la transidentité c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on a comme ça comme une
lubie ou commune une envie
ou c'est vraiment quelque chose qui nous
mine au fond de nous et que tout ce qui
est heureux ou tout ce qui est génial
dans la vie se transforme toujours avec
un arrière pensée de tristesse dans
lequel on dit mais pourquoi je vis là en
tant qu'homme alors que je suis une
femme ou que ce serait vraiment génial
que je puisse vivre ça en tant que femme
donc on laisse passer les zones et
on assume ce que l'on met en place parce
qu'au départ on lutte contre soi même
surtout dans dans cette époque où il y
avait des stéréotypes très fort on était
un homme on est une femme on pouvait pas
autre chose donc il fallait il fallait
se forger un personnage et donc du coup
ce personnage même je pensais que il
allait gagner la bataille on va dire de
l'identité mais pas du tout on ne peut
pas se remplacer on peut pas remplacer
lettre que l'on est au fond de soi ce
qui fait que j'ai attendu j'ai attendu
par à manger attendu par parra sincérité
tout simplement auprès des proches avec
qui j'avais fait toute ma vie sauf qu'au
moment donné je me suis aperçu que ce ne
serait pas du tout possible de continuer
comme ça donc je ne peux rien moi je m'y
attendais car le déclic pour moi c'était
que je me travestissait et pour les
joints ces moments de féminité pour me
retrouver dans un an
dans cette peau de la femme que j'étais
et petit à petit je savais que la
transition serait mon salut mais mais je
ne le faisais pas j'en avais peur sur
les conséquences ce qui fait que j'ai
retarder retarder pendant
15 ans au final et pour aboutir un jour
à ce que mon épouse drôme sur des
affaires et puis comme une grande
explication voilà et on imagine que
c'est une onde de choc aussi pour votre
entourage votre femme vous venez de
l'évoquer vous vos enfants aussi votre
maman comment est ce que on réagit
autour de vous c'est un tsunami il
s'abat l'oeil tout ce que tout ce qu'il
ya autour de moi ça le balaye quad d'un
seul cran en quelques heures en quelques
jours
donc les personnes découvrent un autre
personnage découvre une autre identité
et doivent se forger même s'il ya le
respect même si l amour il ya quand même
une personne qui devient une autre
personne encore attendre que c'est c'est
quelque part une forme de trahison
auprès des personnes à qui je ne l'ait
pas dit alors c'est une trahison dans le
sens où c'était pour eux que je le
faisais donc mais quand je m'imaginais
sur mon lit de mort on me disant mais
est ce que je le dis dans un texte
d'aujourd'hui jockey j'ai vécu une vie
super mais je me serais jamais connu je
me suis mis les gens diraient
mais pourquoi il l'a pas fait et donc du
coup je me suis alors pourquoi on le
fait pas voilà et tant pis donc
ce sont des
ce sont des passages il ya des comme ça
dans la vie il ya des moments où on se
regarde en face d'une glace et puis on
prend des décisions
qui ont des dommages collatéraux et qui
se transforme si ça s'est bien fait ici
et si les gens y met du sien par une
belle aventure humaine et moi c'est ce
qui s'est passé en deux mois j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance mais que ce soit ma
femme mes enfants mes parents mes amis
en quelques années tout a été réglé ils
connaissent ma nouvelle personne ils ont
retrouvé les traits de caractère de
l'époque donc donc voilà aujourd'hui
c'est rentrer dans l'ordre je reconnais
coûte un extrait du documentaire et et
on en parle juste après
le score
l'une des choses les plus difficiles
quand on passe par la transition c'est
le sentiment d'appartenance
check parce que quand on a une éducation
très stricte
un contexte religieux je dirais même
secteur on ne peut pas s'exprimer
facteurs de ce qui pourrait vous arriver
ensuite
voilà pour cet extrait de notre
documentaire athlètes et transgenres le
double challenge on entend donc eric a
expliqué que l'une des choses les plus
difficiles quand on passe par la
transition c'est le sentiment
d'appartenance ce sont des mots qui vous
parle est une forme de culpabilité à
cette affaire c'est à dire que comme
c'est pas encore rentrer totalement dans
les moeurs contrairement à certains pays
asiatiques d'ailleurs où c'est
totalement rentrer en thaïlande en
thaïlande
où vous pouvez trouver des genres un
petit peu mix reportage un jour envoie
un colonel de police qui qui assure des
déserts un genre mixte un petit peu et
ça ne pose de problème à personne nous
on est vraiment un stéréotype est sûre
sur notre religion judéo-chrétienne sur
les religions judéo-chrétiennes dans
lequel il y à l'homme
parfois dominant et puis la femme qui
fait ce qu'elle peut
en suivant tout ça et point barre et
puis voilà la femme l affaire à des
enfants au monde et l'homme dirige le
monde donc tous serrés au type
évidemment explose au fur et à mesure
des années tant mieux pour l'humanité je
crois et on s'aperçoit qu'une petite
minorité globalement 0 4% de la
population ne se retrouve pas dans les
stéréotypes hommes-femmes
est bon on cherche toujours les facteurs
et toujours des gens qui cherchent ce
facteur mais je crois que c'est pas le
problème pas le sujet le sujet c'est que
faire de ces minorités et de les
accepter dans la vie si on a une forme
d'inclusion
on l'est on les accepte sauf que ça pose
différents problèmes et c'est vrai que
dans les futures générations il n'aura
pas problème ans je vois bien avec la
génération de mes enfants et celle
d'après
et enfin qu'il est encore petit
très petit mais déjà la génération de
mes enfants ils ont plus de problèmes
avec ça c'est plus tabou on sait très
bien on connaît donc ils ont d'autres
problèmes à venir notamment le
réchauffement climatique à gérer puisque
ça et c'est vrai que les gens qui
dirigent aujourd'hui c'est des gens qui
diront qu'ils sont dans la génération on
va dire 40 70 ans et ses générations la
bine ont été éduqués avec ces
stéréotypes donc aujourd'hui la religion
vient
souvent
empêché cette transformation de la
société et c'est bien dommage pour
revenir sur la transformation de votre
corps toutes les personnes transgenres
ne souhaitent pas forcément
nécessairement changer anatomiquement de
sexe vous aussi vous allez subir
plusieurs trans plusieurs opérations
chirurgicales vous suivent aussi un
traitement
d'hormonothérapie on imagine que la
transition la transformation et un long
et très lourd processus comment est ce
possible en après ont toutes ces
nouvelles sensations et qu'elle est si
elles existent la prise en charge en
france
alors on a beaucoup de chance en france
puisque la transidentité est bien
accompagné au niveau 2 au niveau des
praticiens au niveau d'insécurité
sociale de l'état qui ont qui aide
vraiment les personnes transgenres à
faire leur transition
donc au niveau chirurgicale les choses
avancent plutôt bien on va dire
notamment les chirurgies du visage ou ou
la main avec tommy pour les trans de
femmes vers rome et le reste des des
opérations générales et autres tout ce
qui peut permettre de s'approprier un
nouveau corps âme puisse en adéquation
avec le genre que l'on colonna dans le
cerveau
est bien en france aujourd'hui on peut
se sentir on va dire bien accompagné
malheureusement ce n'est pas forcément
le cadre beaucoup dans tous les pays
et ses longues c'est un processus qui
est long donc je dire que c'est plus une
fois qu'on a fait la transition que le
problème est là généralement on est
acceptée la société c'est cette phase
transitoire notamment chez les jeunes
qui peut durer entre trois et cinq ans
donc et souvent ce sont des
problématiques au niveau de la scolarité
au niveau du sport au niveau de la
culture de la musique fait un petit peu
tout il ya aussi le changement au niveau
de taissy ville ça aussi c'est un
changement d'état civil à la refaire
tout à fait un c'est ça le problème
c'est qu'aujourd'hui il faut vraiment
avoir fait une transition complète pour
avoir un état civil changé et on ne peut
pas mettre une personne saine quand on
pose dans la société parce que sans gens
sensés état civil ne correspondent pas à
sa transition et au personnel à personne
qu'elle va devenir donc tout l'enjeu il
a aujourd'hui notamment en sport
comment on fait pour accompagner une
personne en cours de transition sachant
qu'elle n'a pas les papiers adéquat
pareil pour l'éducation pareil dans tous
les secteurs de la société comment est
ce qu'on vit tant d'années dans un corps
qui n'est pas le bon je crois que le
sport vous a beaucoup pdo champions
olympiques on le rappelle de kayak 20
ans avant votre transition pourquoi ce
sport pourquoi alors la compétition de
haut niveau qu'est ce que ça représente
à ce moment là dans votre cheminement
aujourd'hui on va dire que quand une
personne se ressentent différentes
salles à deux reflex c'est soit de
rejeter ce cas les immédiatement et il
ya des personnes qui font des
transitions tôt parce que ils
s'aperçoivent très tôt que ils ne
pourront pas vivre dans le genre qui
leur a été assigné à la naissance
et puis d'autres personnes comme moi ou
on se regarde dans la glace on n'est pas
on n'est pas schizophrène on ne voit pas
d'autres personnes on ne dit rien si en
nous mêmes de nous faire notre notre
propre jugement et on se dit c'est juste
pas possible voilà donc il ya une zone
de flou qui apparaît qui peut durer très
très longtemps avec on va dire des
soubresauts on a l'impression qu'on
gagne la partie dans un genre puis
l'autre nous ramène ainsi de suite ce
qui amène aujourd'hui des jeunes
d'ailleurs à revendiquer une certaine
fluidité de genre puisqu'ils font un peu
des va-et-vient je me sens un peu garçon
puis maintenant je me sens de filles et
puis ainsi de suite donc tout ça nous on
les a connus à l'époque ces fluctuations
sauf qu'on ne revendique pas un statut
quoi c'est simplement la différence avec
aujourd'hui
il ya peu de gens on va dire il y en a
il ya peu de gens qui à la proche de la
quarantaine ou la cinquantaine n'ont pas
défini un cadre définitif donc il faut
laisser le temps aux gens de
s'apprivoiser 1 c'est un tout petit peu
plus long que le principe de
l'homosexualité on veut on connaît bien
aussi ce principe là où pour les gens se
découvre dans le tard puisque les
stéréotypes encore sont très forts à la
naissance à une fille on va lui parler
de ses petits copains aux copains aux
gars on va leur parler des petites
copines donc tous à encre dans la dans
l'éducation de l'enfant et donc il va
falloir se
désolidariser de cette éducation et ça
peut prendre très longtemps d'autant
plus si la pression sociale familiale
continue à perdurer vous restez avec
nous sandra forgues ont fait une courte
pause et on se retrouve un juste après
et
vous êtes de retour dans le débrief du
doc nous sommes en compagnie de sandra
phoques sont là je crois que vous avez
arrêté la compétition sportive de haut
niveau alors c'est pas forcément lié à
votre transition vous allez nous
l'expliquer quelle est la place des
athlètes transgenres aujourd'hui dans
ces compétitions sportives de haut
niveau quel regard est ce que vous
portez alors effectivement moi je
n'imaginais pas faire la transition au
monde ma carrière tout simplement parce
que des gens n'en parlez pas à l'époque
c'était encore tabou aujourd'hui les
choses sont très différentes
il ya plein de documentaires il ya plein
de choses qui qui on ne la fait qu'on en
parle et ça peut pousser les personnes a
effectivement faire des transitions
beaucoup plus tôt et donc d'apparaître
dans le spectre on va dire de la
pratique du sport en règle générale et
tant mieux et le spectre du sport de
haut niveau ou là effectivement va se
poser la problématique de l'équité des
femmes
et il ya toute une polémique actuelle
qui a été lors des jeux olympiques de
tokyo a avancé sur la participation des
femmes trans dans le dans le sport
féminin et donc pas mal de gens sont
ce sens par ce son
sont portés sur les études sur des
commentaires sur un certain nombre de
documents
pour essayer de répondre à cette fameuse
question oui ou non les trans dans le
sport donc moi même qui était un petit
peu et quartier de 7 cette réflexion
où j'avais des a priori comme tout le
monde du coup je me suis vraiment
porté sur le sujet j'ai fait mes propres
études j'ai vécu moi-même on va dire
cette expérience de l'hormonothérapie
qui enlevait globalement 15% de mes
résultats sportifs en termes de
déficiences ans j'ai pu mesurer parce
que façon très amatrices je me suis
lancé dans le marathon et en six mois
dans mon et thérapie je suis passé de
3h15 ou marathon à 3h50 en six mois avec
le même entraînement les mêmes muscles
avec tous pareils donc vous avez perdu
en performance donc j'ai perdu 15 % de
mes performances environ là où la
meilleure marathonienne du monde n'était
qu'à 10% du meilleur sommes
inférieures donc
j'ai voulu en savoir davantage je me
suis posé toutes ces questions est
effectivement tout ce que j'ai entendu
jusqu'à présent ne colle pas avec la
réalité du terrain est il vraiment
important de remettre les les bonnes les
bonnes réponses aux bonnes questions
alors on va écouter à nouveau un nouvel
extrait de notre documentaire cette fois
ci au sujet de l'incidence d'une
transition de genre sur les performances
sportives et puis je fait réagir juste
après
un
[Musique]
autre effet secondaire de la prise de
l'austro jet et qu'on commence à prendre
des kilos à des endroits où on en avait
évidemment pas vrai c'est à dire que les
5 pouces comprend aussi du poids sur les
hanches les fesses levante match tarmac
depuis ma transition j'ai des problèmes
de poids que je n'avais jamais
auparavant
quand je jouais au football auparavant
j'étais beaucoup plus endurante j'étais
plus fort je pouvais faire 40 pompe
d'affilée ça ne posait aucun problème
les développé couché les flexions des
biceps les pois avec lesquels je
m'entraînais c'est drôle à quel point
c'était différent de ce que je fais
maintenant
est ce qu'il fait donc débat en ce
moment dans le sport c'est cette
question de l'avantagé biologique d
homme devenu femme lorsqu'on entend à
l'instant américain visiblement il n'y a
pas vraiment davantage la même scène
qu'on veuille en fait c'est tout le
contraire c'est à dire que ok il ya la
carapace initial qui a été formé par les
hormones masculines donc on va avoir des
membres plus longues on va avoir une
certaine un certain gabarit qui peut
impressionner mais globalement les
acteurs fonctionne ans qui font
fonctionner ce mot ce véhicule n'y sont
plus quoi c'est à dire que le bras plus
long il faut un muscle
plus forte pour le mou voire or si on
n'a plus le muscle plus fort pouvoir ça
devient un handicap donc en fait l'autre
notre grand gabarit ou nous aux plus
lourds ou faire tout ce qui est
aujourd'hui nous est amenée comme
argument contre les trans dans le sport
au contraire ils vont dans le sens de
l'handicap que l'on peut avoir à
trimballer une carcasse dont on a pu les
mécanismes pour le mouvoir il ya une
chute drastique du taux d'hématocrite
par exemple où moi je m'étais affolé
dans mes prises de sang alors de
l'endocrine au qui me disait mais non
mais c'est complètement normal voilà
votre turin taux de femmes aujourd'hui
ah oui j'aime et c'est quand même ce qui
transporte l'oxygène dans le sang il me
fait oui bien sûr donc je ne comprenais
pas pourquoi je m'essouffle est plus
vite alors que j'avais les mains muscles
qui plus est la testostérone est un
dopant on le sait du coup lorsqu'on n'a
plus les muscles ça fait cela
l'efficience du réflexe musculaire
s'affaisse et donc vous tombez au
contraire même dans un dans une amie que
vous avez une grosse voiture avec un
tout petit moteur et dans cet handicap
alexia cerenis par exemple a fait il a
bien dit c'est faire un coma par
par un placage d'une fille moi même je
me suis mise au handball féminin dans un
dans le cadre à matrix mais je me fais
retourner comme les autres coiffé g ok
pour eux si je joue contre une fille
d'un mètre cinquante gels avantage de m
77 mais si je joue sur avec une fille de
m 77 kg et la calle moyenne des équipes
de france fait des équipes de haut
niveau de nationale 1 en handball donc
je suis pas plus grande qu'elle
mais je suis pas du tout physiquement à
leurs auteurs
effectivement moi aussi je servais 130
kg au développé couché quand j'étais
athlète aujourd'hui j'arrive pas à faire
cinq pompes donc
le problème c'est que le gabarit que
l'on aimé
donne cette impression de supériorité et
c'est faux mais comment est-ce que vous
expliquer alors ces débats dans le sport
notamment est ce que finalement c'est
bien qu'on en parle davantage de cette
trans identité elle reste méconnue dans
la société et c'est ça qui est porteur
aussi à d'un certain nombre
d'incompréhensions mais comme tout
nouveau sujet il fait peur il ya la peur
qui s'installe et les féministes
extrémistes sont emparés du sujet en
comme dans leurs intellectuels déjà
elles ont du mal à accepter l'idée qu'on
puisse être des femmes ont essayé de
combattre cela en disant mais ce sont
des hommes et qui viennent jouer dans le
camp des femmes mais c'est pas du tout
ça on est complètement à côté de la
réalité donc il n'ya pas de polémique le
combat des femmes je crois il est commun
à toutes les femmes femmes trans compris
la place du sport dans la place des
femmes dans le sport devra évoluer
positivement et pas forcément en
diminuant les trans et peut-être aussi
en proposant aux femmes et aux jeunes
filles de nouvelles activités parce
qu'il n'y a rien de plus stéréotypé que
le sport féminin voilà si vous êtes
grande et fine vous allez faire du
volley si vous êtes grande et qu'on
retrouve d'aller faire du basket si vous
êtes petit vous allez allez faire de la
gym mais on va dire on va jamais dire à
une fille qui fait mettre 70 d'aller
faire de l'haltérophilie alors que tous
les garçons ont une majorité de faire
une capacité d'ouverture dans les
différents sports qui est beaucoup plus
forte et donc moi je pense que c'est le
sport féminin dans son ensemble qu'il
faut revoir ou l'apprentissage du sport
chez les filles qu'il faut revoir on
parle de plus en plus de la transition
hormones et en ce moment qu'on associe à
la dysphorie de genre dans les débats la
dysphorie de genre c'est ce mal être qui
ait provoqué entre son sexe biologique
et son identité de genre en france les
demandes de transition de genre ont été
multipliées par cinq depuis 2012 selon
l'assurance maladie et cela concerne de
plus en plus de mineurs et d'adolescents
comment est-ce que vous l'expliquer
c'est comme le phénomène de
l'homosexualité dans les années sont dit
c'est à dire que toutes ces personnes
l'était déjà le nombre de personnes qui
fait moi j'ai des témoignages de
personnes personne n'imaginait une seule
seconde ces personnes transidentitaires
ils ont toujours cachés ils n'osent pas
ils sont complètement
bloqués dans leur dans leur genre enfin
dans leurs cordes eu du mauvais genre et
ils le disent très clairement ils n'ont
pas le courage de le montrer ni de le
dire et ce n'est pas une personne
transgenre moi je n'étais pas du tout
féminine je n'étais pas un garçon
efféminé oisans vosges était même plutôt
très viril à l'époque donc
votre voisin peut très bien être
tranchant sans le dire ou homosexuels
sont le dire donc que ces chiffres qui
sont assez similaires juste c'est juste
de visibilité c'est plus de visibilité
plus d'acceptation donc les jeunes
disent maintenant stop on arrête avec la
discrimination et on s'affiche donc
petit à petit on va arriver ouvrait
nombre de personnes transidentitaires
dans qui est une va dire tout simplement
la diversité biologique de l'être humain
et dans lequel tout a été dit mais
surtout son contraire il y à des
facteurs biologiques à cela il ya des
facteurs sociaux il ya le facteur nous
multiples qui amena à cela aujourd'hui
on n'a pas toutes les réponses on
commence à en avoir
mais bon on verra bien si si on aura la
vraie réponse un jour en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'il ne faut pas attendre
ses réponses là pour nous accepter comme
accepté l'ensemble des minorités humaine
dans la société est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que la société française la
france s'est saisie de ce sujet de la
trans identité
oui je crois que globalement on peut
être satisfait en france
par rapport si on fait l'état du monde
on fait partie comme des pays dans
lequel la population
est la plus favorables à l'acceptation
des personnes trans dans la société
alors au niveau administratif ça reste
très complexe pour des problématiques de
droits pour des problématiques
on va dire tout simplement de
d'organisation de la société donc les
choses avancent petit à petit les
associations de défense des personnes
trans forme boulot extraordinaire
ce qui a été fait par le passé qu'ils
continuent rien n'est gagné parce que
parce qu'il ya toujours une petite
frange de population
qui raconte tout simplement n'importe
quoi ou qui associés encore cela une
maladie comme on pourrait associer
aujourd'hui je suis pas dans la peau
noire à une maladie une facétie où les
yeux bleus ou les yeux marron à à une
maladie enfin si n'importe quoi une
différence n'est pas forcément livre
nouvel outil enfin le contraire donc on
entend encore dans les médias et
notamment l' approche des élections
toujours quelques personnes qui
racontent strictement n'importe quand
méconnaissance complète des choses pour
brosser dans le poêle une frange de
population
qui a peur du changement ont tout
simplement je voudrais vous faire réagir
aussi cette circulaire parue à l'école
le 27 septembre dernier c'est une
circulaire pour accompagner les élèves
tranchant avec des mots qui sont très
forts les personnes transgenres ont des
droits est dictée par des textes
internationaux européens et par la
législation française la trans identité
est un fait qui concerne l'institution
scolaire les enseignants ont le devoir
d'accompagner les jeunes et de faire
preuve à leur endroit de la plus grande
bienveillance de leur laisser la
possibilité d'explorer une variété de
cheminement sans les stigmatiser ou les
enfermer dans l'une ou l'autre voie
comment est ce que vous avez accueilli
ce texte pas très positivement et ce
n'est que le 1er 2 d'un grand nombre et
à une charte du sport et trans qui est
en train d'être édictées sur un groupe
interministériel
alors laquelle j'appartiens qui rendent
les associations
de défense des personnes trans ont
apporté énormément de de réponses
positives dont je crois que le
vocabulaire aujourd'hui commence à être
connu
aujourd'hui il faut donner des outils
aux gens pour appréhender la
transhumance et je crois que c'est là il
faut les éduquer les gens qui n'ont
jamais eu connaissance de cela avec
toute une partie de connaissances et
lorsqu'on connaît les choses dont les
appréhende de mieux c'est vrai que les
enseignants n'avaient pas de on va dire
d'outils pour pouvoir appréhender ne
sachant pas s'il avait le droit ou pas
de changer le prénom d'une personne à
son besoin donc il fallait donner un
cadre que l'éducation nationale a donné
et tant mieux et encore une fois ça
n'est que le début je pense que tout ça
va progresser dans les années avec le
recul quel regard est ce que vous portez
sur votre parcours quelles ont été vos
plus grandes difficultés vos plus belles
victoires aussi
disons que déjà c'est un choix
on parle souvent ou est ce que la
personne elle a choisi ça n'a rien
choisi du tout vous n'avez pas choisi
d'avoir les oreilles comme ça ou d'avoir
un bras comme ça ainsi de suite quelqu
un outil né avec un handicap il ne
choisit pas d'avoir cet handicap là nous
on est un tout petit peu handicapé par
cette trans identité qui fait que la
société nous aident à
arriver dans le bon dans le bon camp au
moins dans l'apparence de ce corps là
puisque dans la tête on l'est déjà
donc cette aide est très précieuse parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui avaient
opté plus pour le suicide que parce
qu'ils n'avaient pas les moyens on
n'avait pas les moyens de faire cette
transition donc la france prenne à bras
le corps ce sujet très intéressant moi
ce que j'en retire c'est une fierté
d'être moi même d'être authentique en
fait je pense que si toutes les
personnes étaient authentiques on
vivrait dans une meilleure société plus
agréable moi j'appelle à l'amour des
gens à
à la beauté chez chacune des personnes
on peut trouver le meilleur n'est pas
obligé à aller chercher le pire est il
devant sa porte c'est souvent un gage de
sincérité merci beaucoup pour votre
témoignage sandra forgues je rappelle le
nom notre documentaire athlètes et
transgenres le double challenge merci à
vous nous avoir suivis vous pouvez
retrouver ce numéro du débrief du doc
sur notre site internet rt france ce
point tva plus tard
[Musique]
le